this episode brought to you by skill
share classes taught by expert
practitioners for your career or for
your passions the first 500 people who
sign up receive a free two-month trial
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
Halloween is all about monsters
different looks different powers
different personalities and how they
interact with others but we're realizing
what's even more interesting than
monsters interacting with people as
monsters interacting with monsters what
if all those distinct extremist
characters came together would they get
along with a fight or when they fall
somewhere in between this is an idea
that can and has been awesomely
exploited and I've sellouts and
nostalgia ween are no different so let's
bring some of the craziest monsters
together Jason the Rinker jigsaw the
Invisible Man these are some of the most
iconic yet different movie monsters have
ever been given to us together at last
and of course they're all bound together
by one common denominator the one
element of which the majority of focus
should be on their accountant the IRS
requires filing a tax return in each
year that your income is greater than
your standard deduction plus add on one
exemption if you are not the depart
what's going on taxpayer he's the one
thing that binds you all together
yeah but he's like really boring you are
probably racking up interest what did
you think that people really just want
to see you cool badass monsters together
yeah pretty much no no they want to see
a dull guy with no personality
constantly steal the spotlight this is
bullshit I assure you it's not I assure
you it's bullshit no I'm just copying
the master of rebooted monster movies
that Stephen Sommers the brilliant mind
behind GI Joe Rise of Cobra
you know the guy behind the money The
Mummy Returns van Helsing what a SAP
oestrus piece of puss
a most amazing idea with some of the
world's most amazing monsters has turned
into a most amazing snore fest this is
because most of the time is centered
around David effects fake action and a
main character so cool and you could
call him bland did that analogy seem
bland and it fits the character
perfectly with Dracula the Wolfman the
Frankenstein monster Jekyll and Hyde
this should've been a kick-ass thrill
ride but instead feels like skid marks
and the Scorpion Kings underwear so what
went wrong with this gritty reboot of
Abbott and Costello well let's look in
more detail unless our exciting main
character has more thrilled to give us
it's important to understand American
Opportunity Credit this is worth up to
2,500 per student for the first four
this is bullshit
let's take a look at Van Helsing we open
with the universal logo where's the dark
universe a uh-oh shoo shoo see an angry
mob so subtle unbelievable you'd swear
they were from The Count Chocula
commercial my marshmallows they head
towards the castle Frankenstein in
Transylvania yeah all of those Germans
who have skipped over to Romania as the
doctor has brought his classic monster
to life pleasing his good friend Count
Dracula played by Richard Roxburgh who's
becoming because of death around here if
it's your moment of triumph he's being
spoiled so very different thing like
grave robbery
so what's brought I can't really say
it's a good Dracula but here's a lot of
fun in this honestly this whole intro is
kind of entertaining in a Sin City meats
13 ghosts of scooby-doo wait peculiar
experiments that made you unwell in most
of this civilized world
that was my tribute to months to squaw
trust me there'll be a lot more
references to that than the universal
movies
Dracula wants the monster for himself
and it seems even Igor has betrayed the
good doctor he got you
he's okay to me doctor okay thought and
they said they'd never make another
white chicks you totally can ow
the monster attacks Dracula though and
carries the doctor to the windmill but
Imhotep oh come on eh um peed on that
one thank you it's not done yet with him
and his wives tried to catch him as the
villagers burn down the mill the monster
sums up the movie's existence in one
word why because we hate you
all joking aside this opening is pretty
awesome
it's silly but it's an over-the-top take
on classic monster themes and shadows
and angles and gothic melodrama at first
you might think this is gonna be a lot
of fun but then it goes to color I think
actually what wasn't this whole movie
shot in black and white just looks like
the negative was thrown in the washer
with pinheads clothes introduced to one
of our main characters played by Kate
Beckinsale Hugh Jackman who plays the
title role of van Helsing
they say he's hunting mr. high but I
don't know he looks like the big
friendly Giants testicle wart my
superiors would like for me to take you
alive
doulas the scene is once again fake and
cheesy but a little bit of fun is high
too swung around no trade down
surprisingly not making a bad hunchback
joke guess they figured Disney would do
that as he transforms back into jekyll
before hitting the ground did he say
really Scott's apology like heaven and
go buddy he's never gonna ask for
forgiveness for that
that kick-ass Alan Silvestri's score
picks up again for the Vatican as he
enters his secret headquarters
it looks like the Vatican is a giant
meeting place of religious leaders who
hunt down different monsters all over
the world oh is that why so many of the
world's religions get along so well
we have kept safe since time immemorial
and now we need you to go to the east
was that guy just waiting for the snap
like that was his entire job you are the
hunter of monsters and you you are deep
or short buttons I know it's not as
glamorous but I can't do it
wait yes I can you are fired push or
fart tons by a certain count he's told
to hunt down Dracula by helping the
princess of gypsies Anna for more than
four centuries the who I have to get her
shampoo but because he's double O slayer
he also needs cool weapons so we get
David Wenham playing a friar named Karl
Pryor Karl isn't that like having a st.
Bob you've never gone after vampires
before now heavy vampires goggles
warlocks throw the same oh well good to
know that van Helsing doesn't know the
difference between a vampire and a
gargoyle vampires goggles warlocks throw
same milk alcohol poison it's all the
same to give a baby that's why you're
coming with me
oh they held it down their hand you're a
monk you shouldn't curse at all actually
I'm still just a friar I can curse all I
want damn it uh uh you were Faramir now
you're the embarrassing cartoon designed
to make everyone else look cooler by
comparison it's funny because I'll never
look like you with my shirt off
meanwhile a gypsy prince is left out for
bait to catch a werewolf when things go
wrong though his sister played by Kate
Beckinsale weirdly typecast as werewolf
and vampire hunters comes in to save him
ish
well my characters totally established
now oh yeah don't expect a lot of
backstory personality or even interest
out of this person much like our main
lead she's just there to do stuff and
look good while doing it the only
problem is so many people look good
while doing stuff and have charming
personalities that the simple act of not
smiling doesn't give you a
three-dimensional character you have to
talk about things interesting things not
just shitty plot exposition like this
why is it so important to kill this
Dracula anyway because he's the son of
the devil I mean besides that because if
we kill him anything big no that's
enough do you really need more
motivation than that welcome to
Transylvania I was just about to do the
time-warp again you turn around so van
Helsing goes to I just realized this a
snowy European Kingdom in the 1800s to
talk to Princess Anna Disney really is
trying to buy everything but oh no our
two main characters are meeting and we
have an established shit about them no
really I don't know a goddamn thing
about their desires personalities
anything it's the director going to a
give us some insight into the person at
now you know it's be panic yep they
talked for 35 seconds before giving us
another goddamn action sequence oh I'm
excited this bland chunk of wood is
fighting alongside this dry piece of
cardboard
what will the boring one do to save the
other boring one this is like seeing
really cool monsters go up against a can
of soup
this is bullshit
so trick ulis wives attack and again
they're pretty silly but at least they
have personality see that was stupid but
at least I'll remember it
we saw random questions that way do you
have any to paper or plastic daddy would
you like some sausage that would fit too
well what is up with the editing by the
way I swear I'm not tampering with this
it's so rushed and chaotic I can't even
make it out
but the hell was that just random
moments in time of him getting hit
if you don't establish a narrative to
the action we lose interest really
quickly anyone can just cut to random
shots of people being punished see not
exciting
Who am I kidding that girl Mike Tyson is
always excites how they use holy water
that's super soak one of them to death
forgive me Father I said yes to this
movie he's the first one to kill a
vampire in over a hundred years
so van Helsing earns Anna's trust but
Dracula is so furious he pulls a Mavis
pounding up the walls I guess that's a
vampire thing don't try to out hand me I
worked with John Woo and Baz Luhrmann I
have so much ham I need to insured's so
Anna talks about her motivation her
passion and overall what makes her tick
not just kidding they talk about stuff
they did and stuff they're going to do
where do I find Dracula
yes used to live in this very house four
centuries ago I can help mm-hmm so when
does she get kidnapped
funny thing tough people don't have to
actually say they're tough people they
just act that way so when someone has to
prove they're not a damsel in distress
it's usually lazy Ryan clarifying that's
exactly what they are I can take care of
myself I'm a damsel I'm in distress I
can handle this and seeing what empty
shells these two are it probably won't
be long until she can't handle her ass I
didn't think it'd be that quick van
Helsing I don't even really get it why
do you knock her out was it to protect
her a lot of good that did her brother
sneaks in transformed into a werewolf
and tries to kill her was he using your
as bait to catch the werewolf oh he sure
wasn't on guard when the where we'll
finally made this booth
thank got you once I still unconscious
when he broke in van dumbass
she well Faribault let go in it did why
do we focus on that lazy we didn't
graves didn't it
never too late to degrade so the town
Undertaker tries to pointlessly kill him
it's just my nature ha ha
but the werewolf attacks and Helsing
tries to kill it with an ax stopping him
to werewolf he's gonna kill people I
know but anyway
do you understand forgiveness yes so you
can forgive me when I kill him you have
to have memories of those you loved and
lost is not that will dive into those
memories because then you'd have dad
let's just go find literal hair of the
dog who bit me but fear not we have this
amazing insight as they chased the wolf
to Frankenstein's castle it's just after
death did your father went missing he
was on his way to the sea I've never
been to the sea but it's beautiful
sucks you know weird thing maybe would
you talk about personal stuff during
personal scenes and strategic stuff
during strategic scenes not the other
goddamn way around but fine to give us
some more information on your
fascination with the simmer of such a
nuisance
I guess it stops there that's all we
need to have a fascinating character I
guess yeah I guess I should do something
like that for my main characters
development to pull out your federal and
state tax returns from the previous year
I like pies for income information
you'll need the PM to receive from your
employer and banks so they come across
Dracula's unborn well they're born and
they're just dead because he's Undead
which means alive so they should be
alive you know I'll just let them
explain it to pimpare said the walking
dead it only makes sense that children
are born dead clear that up ladies first
so naturally I'll go first where do you
get your shampoo by the way it looks
like Dracula wants to use Frankenstein's
technology to bring his offspring to
life and Ana's brother is a slave to his
word now as well as these random guys
Boombah Boombah du petit death at least
we're not working for Johnny Depp the
technology seems to work giving birth to
vampire Mon and they rushed the village
to feed Dracula Pines Helsing bowing
confronts it it's the only applies
you're gonna get in this movie might as
well drag it out do you exactly what is
it I should be remembered what a big
seeds of ancients past how do you know
me because I have a 50/50 chance you're
gonna play someone who doesn't know his
backstory branch out man memory a little
details from know to show it's too
horrifying
that's not okay lah Oh Hellsing an an
escape and the fat babies explode not
having a very long lifespan it would
appear the good doctor took the key to
life please Dave let me take a shit here
in peace Wolfie clogged up the toilet
again our heroes come across the old
windmill to hide out it okay cool maybe
now we're gonna find out more about that
door the set itself tries to kill them
I really couldn't blame it take a guess
who they happen to stumble across though
actually to the film's credit it does
follow the book a little more of having
the monster actually be intelligent and
well-spoken
I guess that's enough to convince
Helsing not to kill him my job is to
vanquish even this thing evil may have
created it and evil does not rule it so
I cannot kill it well if I didn't seem
to stop you when innocent Jekyll was
falling to his death in fact what did
they say about your unnecessary killings
you can't then didn't you that's why
they get so annoying when they ask you
to bring someone back they didn't mean
just actually kill us then your
humanitarian ass so they tried to get
the muster to Rome
to protect him from Dracula I guess this
could be nice we can find out more about
one of literature's most famous
characters that big oh where are you
going to go I don't know if you've
looked in the mirror lately but you kind
of stick out to the crowd ha ha
please tell me that's not it movies have
been made about this character and
you're just doing another Disney Pixar
action sequence because yeah
why have crap like this and now out of
the Silence of the night has brought two
of my lonely children together
[Music]
when we can have high art like this this
is the stupidest thing I've ever done
and I was an accident origins after
falling down the frigging longest cliff
ever the monsters are fought off with
Anna's brother biting the dust you know
that's why they call you murderer
because you kill people that's the
stupidest line in this movie well well
that's a development maybe now they'll
finally have a conversation about the
good price this is a character
development or a monster movie or even a
movie it's Steven summers playing with
his dolls
I'm the wow you're the oh who cares
you're kidnapped
oh no what's my backstory your backstory
is blablabla what one of your
brilliantly written scripts are needed
sir
knock out my door knock-knock dog yes
sir drew see anything no sir I didn't
see Universal giving you millions of
dollars can God well that all sounded
great how about a budget of 160 million
sounds good Universal
[Applause]
[Music]
you've got some mad skills but dare I
say they could be improved oh yes I went
there but you're not alone for example I
love drawing and doing animation but
I've only kind of done it on Photoshop I
never learned professionally how to do
it but luckily Skillshare has a ton of
classes that show you how skill share is
an online learning community with more
than 20,000 classes and design photo
animation and so much more I found a
really great one about how to do
animation on Adobe After Effects even if
you have no experience with it
whatsoever all beginners and newcomers
are welcome the teachers are great that
go out a very steady pace and they're
super super informative whatever skill
you're looking to improve or even start
skills share probably has a class for it
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access so you can improve your skills
unlock new opportunities and just
flat-out do the work you love Skillshare
also believes in accessible learning and
the price definitely reflects that an
annual subscription with unlimited
access is less than ten dollars a month
just ten dollars a month making it one
of the best deals you can find for
online education and Sen skills chair is
sponsoring this video the first 500
people to use the promo link in the
description will get the first two
months free to try out risk-free that's
so many classes you can check out and
enjoy whatever your hobby or your line
of work skills share is definitely gonna
have something for you so definitely
check Skillshare out the first 500
people that sign up will receive a two
month free trial all you have to do is
go to this link to start your trial now
Skillshare opportunity is waiting to be
worked
[Music]
[Applause]
so where humans walk into town looking
like the opening of a joke if they're
approached by one of Dracula's wives
that's the laughable woman who suddenly
realized there were killer dogs on the
other side of that wall she says there's
a masquerade ball where they can make
the trade allowing some of our
characters to dress like what they
really are you won't turn into a
werewolf
until the writing of your first full
moon even then you'll still be able to
fight Dracula's hold over you until the
final stroke of midnight this whole
movie is that blue tart from Skyward
Sword who keeps telling you things you
have to do just let me play the damn
game yeah I guess it figured Helena
Bonham Carter would be in this oh that's
not her she can see the director asked
that performers that everyday you make
my skin crawl
and my dubbing sloppy they spot van
Helsing though and also reveal they've
captured the Frankenstein monster they
managed to rescue Anna though and
escaped into the water they talked with
who did your job they shared a sentence
that's what the director considers
friendship I wouldn't be that
heartbroken even if you somehow killed
that unibrow Moses you to destroy
Frankenstein as well but Frankenstein is
dead oh you mean the monster because
this movie is so bad it actually made
the common mistake of calling the
monster Frankenstein that's actually
kind of amazing for any Frankenstein
movie to do that's like in breath of the
wild somebody calling link Zelda it's
not just a mistake
it's an embarrassing mistake I've time
to keep bringing up Zelda games by the
way I guess I just feel a lot more for
those pixels then these pixels in fact
I'm still not entirely convinced these
two aren't computer-generated so they
find out the map Anna's father had in
his castle was actually a gateway that
leads to Dracula I don't even care how
that works
funny how the snow goes sideways and yet
our hair isn't moving at all
captain Civic wait for me crisis still
sounds stupid it discover the monster oh
my bad
Frankenstein it's sealed inside a zebra
cake which looks so ridiculous
our heroes look like they don't know how
to respond to it Maus no laughs why does
Dracula have a cure I don't care
well at least she's echoing the audience
the capture Igor though and anna hasn't
take her to where the cure is apparently
hidden I'll go first
why doesn't she send Igor in to get it
goodness obviously be a trap
the wives drops in and they have
themselves a bat fight while the weenie
sidekicks have their own little battle
this is like watching a fight from the
pig in the chicken from mallanna
this isn't especially interesting
meanwhile van Helsing goes to free the
monster off the table and grabs onto a
wire swinging across the castle knocking
out Igor
goodbye Benny I can handle myself thank
you
but Dracula appears to Van Helsing at
elbow that see him as night on doll
Mountain van Helsing turns into a
werewolf and what should be really cool
is so ridiculously fake you'd swear to
Michael Bay reboot of Hotel Transylvania
by the way longest 12 strokes of
midnight ever this must've been such a
burden
Dracula reveals get this that van
Helsing was the angel Gabriel who
originally killed him and apparently God
erased his memories cuz that's what God
does now free truth in the Bible let's
see yeah uh-huh you're sending black
powers now I shall give you back good
money some things are better left
forgotten I want this whole movie
without having identity why start now he
bites Dracula because didn't you know
that's the only thing that can kill him
yeah they sparkle too and Ana comes in
to stab them with the cure but the wolf
side of em kills her
oh I'm gonna miss so much about her like
fact that she had a brother
that's what you talked about yeah 160
million dollar budget and they couldn't
even master shooting grass in slo-mo I
don't know I don't know
[Music]
totem that's Latin for she could handle
herself
this dead woman could handle herself
wait Frankie's monster got hosed on
whatever deal they made you know Anna
always wanted to see the seed we never
did anything with that so you're gonna
live in the sea now I did Frankie so in
a spirit I guess he's United with our
family but it looks so corny I keep
expecting to see Elvis from the end of
hotshots up there
so um final line am I actually so boring
you didn't give me a final line come on
guys you must have given me a final
lineup guess not good night everybody
I have no idea what I did any of this oh
I never thought I'd say this but bring
back Brendan Fraser okay pros the
monsters are kind of fun they overact
and look fake but their designs are cool
and there's a lot of charm to them the
sets are cool for all the CG in the
movie it is nice to see how much of
these backgrounds were actually
constructed but the cons the pacing is
non-existent the story's just an excuse
for cartoon action sequences and the
main characters suck there is no reason
to like them outside of they do action
stuff they're given no personality
distract from the actual fun characters
that focus more on what they're doing as
opposed to why they're doing it because
of this it's a super frustrating film
because I want to see a movie with all
these monsters I want to see them fight
I want to see them act off each other
but instead we focus on these bores why
couldn't this film be about Dracula
getting all the monsters together and
what that entails
so yeah the creatures were the coolest
part of the movie it's a shame the movie
itself didn't pick up
so I'm sorry all you monsters are
brought together I really thought I was
giving the audience what they wanted why
don't you shut your mouth we're learning
a lot about taxes there's a relatively
simple way to determine the best choice
for your situation well I guess some
people can find value on anything
especially when it comes to detectable
ice this is extremely helpful I remember
it so you don't have to it's fascinating
so I'm really gonna feel bad Wow
[Music]
you
now you're like my
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out if you've been watching the
news at all you probably heard about
hurricane Michael this has been just
causing all sorts of devastation all
throughout Florida and the southeast so
what we're doing today is that we've
done this charity before I know you've
heard of it but we're gonna do Red Cross
because they've had such this long
history of helping people who have been
in these disasters if you'd like to give
blood that's also an option you can go
to a local blood bank of Red Cross also
does a lot of those if you go there
website you can also see places where
you can donate blood
anything is helpful I mean this time so
many people have lost so much so if you
can definitely click on the link see
what you can do no one deserves to lose
as much as these people have so
definitely click on the link and see
what you can give thank you
you